it was announced yesterday late
afternoon that Brian Williams has been
suspended you hear that yeah and a new
poll just came out it shows Brian
Williams has fallen from number 23 to
number 835 on the most trustworthy
celebrity list it's a huge fall yeah
this puts him right between Kanye West
and Voldemort in the middle you do a
good Voldemort let's hear it very good
your Voldemort's kind of giddy how did
Paul have it's a happy guy NBC has
suspended Brian Williams for six months
without pay no pay yeah
Williams said he's not worried because
soon his veterans benefits will kick in
take care of things yeah
legal marijuana working out for Colorado
apparently yeah a new report says last
year Colorado collected get this 44
million dollars in marijuana taxes yeah
unfortunately they can't remember where
they put it
a lot of green beer Charles Manson in
the news Charles Manson has officially
broken off his engagement to his 27 year
old fiancee
yeah when asked why Manson said her
mother was a total psycho
she's crazy man
you